[Music]
this is a CBS News special report I'm
trying to cope with in New York we are
waiting for what is likely to be more
alarming news on the economy and economy
already devastated by the coronavirus
the Labor Department will announce
weekly unemployment claims momentarily
and they are expected to be in the
millions even more than the nearly 3.3
million announced a week ago that number
was more than ten times what we've been
seeing in recent years it was nearly
five times the all-time record over the
course of the entire Great Recession a
decade or so ago about eight or nine
million jobs were lost we lost a third
of that two weeks ago in a moment we're
gonna find out what the loss was in the
following week a time period during
which the number of states that had shut
down all but essential businesses only
grew at this moment four in five
Americans are in a stay at home shelter
in place state of mind they are not
spending their money and businesses are
laying people off by the millions let's
go now to CBS business analyst Jill
Schlesinger who I believe has a number
for us Jill good morning what is it good
morning I believe that someone just
whispered in my ear 6 more than 6
million I hope that's right because I
just heard a lot of things in my ear at
once and if that is correct that is more
than twice that we saw last week you
know these numbers are so devastating
six point six four million is the actual
number just out by the Labor Department
I want to put this in context as you
said Tony these are numbers that we saw
over the course of the entire Great
Recession
and we don't know how many these people
are going to get back to work and how
quickly but I think the problem is this
is like a flood and the waters are still
rising and it is going to seem like
these numbers are horrible for weeks on
end
but soon we hope that the flood waters
will recede we just don't know when well
Jill I mean six million jobless claims
in one week that is a new record over
the record set the week before and each
one of these jobs lost means another
paycheck that's not being spent in the
community that is not circulating
in the economy how can one job loss lead
to even still more and where does this
put us trajectory wise as we look into
the next quarter you know I think that
as we look at economic growth it is gone
it's obviously come to a standstill and
that started as early as the beginning
of March we are obviously in a recession
already we usually only claim a
recession in retrospect but it's clear
from these numbers that we are there we
are seeing economic output estimates
meaning what's gonna happen in the
economy they're all over the place we
just got one out from the Bank of
America of a more than fifteen percent
drop that we could see in the next
quarter we've seen estimates up to 30
percent but what we really are looking
at here is the unknown and I think that
is why economists are all over the place
with these projections we are not
talking about something we've ever seen
before we're talking about something
that is essentially a health pandemic
that is now morphed into an economic
pandemic and there are too many
variables you know when you have
economists talking to epidemics that we
are going to get estimates all over the
world yeah this is all very new there is
no precedent but somebody with a long
memory on this subject who has covered
the economy for years as our Anthony
Mason's let's go to him with a question
Anthony good morning yeah Jill I'm
wondering if you were running a business
right now you obviously you don't know
what to plan for so how do you plan what
do you do well I think that this goes
back to your basics and I've been
talking to a lot of small business
owners specifically and they are saying
look this program for these front
through the Small Business
Administration which opens tomorrow
could be important but they're looking
at what is my payroll what are my
options what would happen under a number
of scenarios and so when we look at that
together and we start planning out you
see that a lot of these small businesses
do not have eight weeks that they can
fund themselves they don't have 12 weeks
I think that this is going to mean that
many of
these businesses are going to remain
shuttered and they are planning on
remaining shuttered for far longer than
the government programs last and I think
that's the issue here we have a gap
between what people need and what the
government is about to provide and then
Joe thank you very much in that headline
again 6.6 million new unemployment
claims which means over the past two
weeks this country has lost as many jobs
as it lost during the entire two years
of the Great Recession our coverage will
continue on our 24-hour streaming
network cbsn and you can watch it at CBS
news.com
or on our CBS news app there will be
more to come on your local news on this
CBS station and tonight of course on the
CBS Evening News with Norah O'Donnell
many of you will now return to CBS this
morning this has been a CBS News special
report
I'm 22 copal CBS News New York for news
24 hours a day
go to CBS news.com